لديكم 45 يوما ومصالحنا اكثر اهميه منكم
بهذه الكلمات امهلت واشنطن اوكرانيا وكيف
تطلب الامان اجتماع تاريخي للاتحاد
الاوروبي لاول مره في كيف بعد ان اعلن
مدفيديف الجنود البريطانيين اهدافا مشروعه
لندن تتراجع فيما الغرب يتراجع ايضا عن
خططه في اوكرانيا فرنسا ستبرم اتفاقات
عسكريه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه تستنسخ طريقه روسيه
لاستنزاف اسلحه الروس وبوتين يظهر سلاحا
سريا اقوى من القنبله النوويه رساله
بولنديه مباشره الى زيلينسكي الجزائر تنجح
بما فشلت به دول العالم في النيجر في
المغرب تتجدد المخاوف بعد الزلزال المدمر
وانفجار ضخم يهز المملكه البريطانيه الغرب
يشد الحبل
الاوكراني اقدام الولايات المتحده تغوص في
عمق الوحل الاوكراني ليزداد الوضع سوءا مع
مرور الايام وها هو رئيس مجلس النواب
الامريكي كيفن مكارثي يؤكد في مقابله مع
شبكه سي بي اس ان المصالح الامريكيه اكثر
اهميه من تقديم مساعده اضافيه لاوكرانيا
مشيرا الى المشاكل على الحدود الامريكيه
لم ينتهي الامر عند ذلك اكشف نائب
البرلمان الاوكراني ياروسلاف جليز نياك ان
كيف تلقت تحذيرا من واشنطن بضروره عدم
حدوث فضائح فساد في البلاد خلال 45 يوما
على خلفيه اقرار قانون الميزانيه
الامريكيه المؤقته فيما صرح متحدث باسم
البيت الابيض بانهم يمتلكون الاموال
لتلبيه الاحتياجات الفوريه للمساعده
العسكريه لاوكرانيا ولكن الاموال ليست
متوفره للدعم على المدى الطويل ماذا عن
وعودكم بالوقوف مع اوكرانيا حتى النهايه
يا ابناء العمس هل اقترب الاوكران من
الوقوف وحيدين امام دب روسيا هناك لم تجد
كييف امامها سوى طلب الامان من الامريكان
فقد اعلنت اوكرانيا انها تتواصل مع
مسؤولين امريكيين لضمان حصولها على
مساعدات جديده في عقاب توصل الكونجرس الى
اتفاق تمويل للحكومه يحول دون اغلاق
المؤسسات الفيدراليه على خط التخلي عن
اوكرانيا يمضي الغرب عموما حيث كشفت صحيفه
سندي تايمز البريطانيه ان الغرب تخلى عن
خططه بان تستولي اوكرانيا على شبه جزيره
القرم مرجعه ذلك الى خوفها من العواقب
التي ستترتب عن هذا الامر لكن قبل ذلك كان
وزير الدفاع البريطاني جران تابز قد اعلن
ان المملكه المتحده تخطط لتدريب اكثر من
50 ال عسكري اوكراني بحلول نهايه العام
الجاري
2023 على الفور خرج نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي دمتري مدفيدف مهددا بان الجنود
البريطانيين الذين سيقومون بتدريب القوات
الاوكرانيه سيكونون اهدافا مشروعه لروسيا
واعتبر مدفيديف مثل هذه الخطوات من قبل
الغرب تعجل باندلاع حرب عالميه ثالثه
وكانه يقول اذا اردتم حربا لا تبقي ولا
تذر فامضوا في خططكم هذه اليكم المصدر هدد
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي دميت مدف بان
الجنود البريطانيين الذين سيقومون بتدريب
القوات الاوكرانيه سيكونون اهدافا مشروعه
لروسيا وبعد ان استمع رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ريشي سوناك لتهديدات ميدفيدف
ترجع سوناك ونفى وجود خطط لنشر قوات
بريطانيه في اوكرانيا مشيرا الى ان اي
برنامج تدريب داخل هذا البلد لن يجري
حاليا ما اسرع انسحاب عن وعودكم يا احفاد
اليز هل هو خوف ام حرص مع التراجع
الامريكي البريطاني عن دعم اوكرانيا تقدم
الاتحاد الاوروبي لينوب عنهما في اجتماع
تاريخي ولاول مره خارج حدود الاتحاد اجتمع
وزراء خارجيه دول الاتحاد الاوروبي في
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف بهدف التعبير عن
دعم دول التكتل لاوكرانيا يتعهد مسؤول
السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزي بوريل بالتزامات امنيه طويله الام د
مع مزيد من الاسلحه والذخائر ستصل في وقت
سريع لقد اصبح الغربيون محيرين حقا انهم
يلعبون سياسه شد الحبل فبعضهم يشد طرفه
والاخر يرخي طرفه وهكذا يستمر الغرب في
حكايتهم مع اوكرانيا اما في فرنسا فاعلنت
وزاره الدفاع انه تم في ختام زياره وزير
الدفاع سيباستيان لوغن الى كييف مؤخرا
ابرام 16 اتفاقا بين شركات صناعيه عسكريه
فرنسيه واوكرانيه ونحن بانتظار الرد
الروسي الى الاحداث في الميدان الاوكراني
حيث قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
الدفاعات الجويه اعترضت خمسه صواريخ هاي
مارس امريكيه الصنع و37 طائره مسيره
اطلقتها كييف خلال 24 ساعه ياتي ذلك فيما
اعلن الجيش الاوكراني اسقاط 16 طائره
مسيره من اجمالي نحو 30 اطلقتها روسيا على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه من جهته قال قال حكم
منطقه خرسون جنوبي اوكرانيا ان قصفا روسيا
على المنطقه خلال الليل ادى الى سقوط قتيل
على الاقل واصابه سته اخرين بينهم طفلان
واضاف المسؤول الاوكراني ان القوات
الروسيه شنت اكثر من 70 هجوما خلال يوم
لتعود الدفاع الروسيه وتعلن ان القوات
الروسيه دمرت مقرات اربعه الويه اوكرانيه
في دونتسك زبروجيا بينما اعلن المكتب
التمثيلي لجمهوريه دونتسك الشعبيه القوات
الاوكرانيه قصفت اراضي الجمهوريه 33 مره
خلال يوم واطلقت ما مجموعه
133 مقذوفا من عيارات مختلفه ولازلنا في
ميدان المعارك حيث كشف تقرير لصحيفه بول
ستريت جورنال الامريكي ان اوكرانيا تستنزف
الذخائر الروسيه عبر اسلحه مزيفه مصنوعه
من المطاط والخشب واشارت الصحيفه الى ان
العتاد الاوكراني المزيف يشمل انظمه
الدفاع الجي باتريوت ودبابات لبرد اثنين
المانيه الصنع ويعد هذا الامر محاوله
لاستنساخ حركه تقوم القوات الروسيه بها
على الدوام بوضع هياكل مطاطيه على اشكال
طائرات لاستنزاف الاسلحه والمسيرات
الاوكرانيه فلمن ستكون الغلبه وهنا يدخل
بوتين سلاحا مرعبا للرد على الغرب
بالطريقه الروسيه الخاصه حيث كشف تقرير
حديث لصحيفه الديلي ستار البريطانيه
معلومات خطيره عن سلاح بوتين الجديد الذي
اطلق عليه نظام البوجا الصاروخي ويعتمد
على استخدام مبادئ فيزيائيه جديده ويجري
تطويره حاليا في روسيا يستطيع ان يتيح هذا
الصاروخ او القنبله الكيرو مغناطيسيه
تحييد العدو دون اطلاق رصاصه واحده حسب ما
جاء بتقرير الصحيفه البريطانيه وقد اطلق
عليه البوجا اي السلاح السري وهو اقوى من
قنبله النوويه من اوكرانيا الى بولندا فقد
دعاى رئيس الوزراء البولندي ماتيوس مرافيت
السكي الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي
لعدم نسياني ان بولندا قبلت مليوني لاجئ
اوكراني برايكم هل هي رساله من بولندا الى
اوكرانيا بدفع ثمن اقامه اولئك اللاجئين
الاحداث والتطورات في الجزائر اعلنت وزاره
الخارجيه ان النيجر قبلت رسميا المبادره
التي تقدمت بها الجزائر لعوده النظام
الدستوري في البلاد فيما بادر الرئيس
الجزائري عبد المجيد تبون بتكليف وزير
الخارجيه احمد عطاف بالتوجه الى نيام في
اقرب وقت ممكن بهدف الشروع في مناقشات
تحضيريه مع كافه الاطراف المعنيه حول سبل
تفعيل المبادره الجزائريه الى الجره
المغربيه ظهرت بشكل مفاجئ حفره ضخمه في
ضواحي اقليم الجديده غربيه المغرب وسرعان
ما اثارت مخاوف وتساؤلات السكان خصوصا
انها ظرت بعد زلزال الم مر الذي ضرب
البلاد في الثامن من سبتمبر الماضي هز
انفجار ضخم شمال غربي اوكسفورد في
بريطانيا واظهر مقطع فيديو انه اضاء
السماء باللون البرتقالي بعد لحظات من
مرور عاصفه راضيه في السماء وبحسب الميرور
وديلي اكسبريس فان الطاقه تعرضت لانقطاع
مؤقت بعد وقت قصير من
[موسيقى]
الانفجار
ا